I think a lot of people when they get
into business they become too obsessed
with the hyper growth and they forget
the quality that they're trying to build
up that keeps the business stable and
growing for a long time and the question
is is why are you growing there is no
data absolutely zero that says that
hyper growth or fast growth companies
are stronger a better company zero right
it's just a weird human thing that we
want to brag and say I'm a hyper Growth
Company I'm like whatever right so and
we have to think of growth as a dial
right and think of it like yourself
which is like you want to be uh you want
to be healthy it's a dial of how you do
that you can't work out every day you
know as hard as you can you'll actually
break your body so we have to be Crystal
Clear what do we want from these
businesses that we start are we trying
to impact the world are we trying to do
something or do we just want to have a
lifestyle
um because you'll make decisions
accordingly